you want to know why Malcolm Reynolds is
a badass just watch the trailer I'm not
threatening you I'm unarmed good well if
it wasn't established before it's
established now badass space pirates
they shoot first
serenity so serenity is the two-hour
theatrically released conclusion by
Universal notfox which is interesting to
Joss Whedon's Firefly it was written and
directed by him as the first
theatrically released movie that he did
direct for all intents and purposes the
movie shouldn't exist movies don't get
made out of cancelled television shows
this one did because you fight the power
and you win so my review for serenity
here is gonna be spoiler filled here's
my logic for that you wither watch my
review for Firefly or you didn't if he
didn't you don't care about the
fireflies story so spoilers here
shouldn't bother you if you did watch my
review for Firefly you either got
enticed to watch Firefly or you didn't
if you didn't you don't care about
Firefly in which spoilers for serenity
shouldn't bother you if he did watch
Firefly then you got enticed to watch
serenity there's no other option so
you've seen serenity or you don't care
either way spoilers in this review so
the show Firefly really alluded to and
actually established in the last episode
that River Tam is a psychic that plays
into this movie big time because at the
beginning of this movie you see River
Tam being worked on and Simon busts her
out and the Alliance has sent an
assassin after her simply known as the
operative because the guy has no name he
has no rank he just he's a ghost he's
one of those really cool assassin types
also he's really well-spoken it's like
I'm polite I just believe that killing
you is what must happen he'll tell you
you're saying like you know what your
sin is its pride and then he'll kill you
that's a cool assassin right there but
he also tells at the beginning of this
movie the reason the Alliance wants
River Tam back is because she's a
psychic and key members of parliament
personally observed River Tam in which
through her psychic abilities
accidentally gleaned information out of
them information that could be bad for
the alliance so now yeah they want her
killed and with the whole River Tam
having information from the minds of the
people in Parliament you can tell that's
where Joss Whedon was like I had more
planned but I have to sum it up in two
hours so here you go would have been
cool to see where the series went and
how much more he could have added to it
before just having a two-hour window he
does a good job here he focuses the
points that need to be focused and gives
you what you love about Firefly where
you need it and after that now we have
serenity and I love the title segment
and serenity shows the ship its landing
it shows mal in the cockpit with wash
and ultimately you go through the entire
ship and you meet and greet everybody
and then after the first job they go but
that few minutes of mal walking through
and talking with people it all looks
like one shot but actually I think it's
- it shows a scene where it's on mal and
then it goes back to sign
Taman right there I think there's a
splice so it's two shots made to look
like one shot but it's really impressive
by the end of that entire segment of mal
locking through serenity you know
everything you need to know about the
characters and you get the entire tour
of serenity it's a two in one package
perfect way to start this movie out
after you know the assassin killed a
couple people after the crew does their
heist that town gets ravished by Reavers
you finally see Reavers I mean at first
I'm watching the movie or like oh cool
we saw Reavers at least they got to show
them maybe not no they're like the key
ingredient to everything Simon has told
mal after punching him he's like we're
off your boat and mouths like shiny get
out okay Mal's hands are clean he hasn't
outright rivers watching this video feed
and she looks into it and she's just
like then she turns around and proceeds
to beat the [ __ ] out of everyone I'm not
talking she just talks clobbering guys
this chick knows jujitsu
she isn't mite unpredictable mood swings
of a sword it's less than you know it
usually is she's a little weapon she's
an 85-pound weapon for the Alliance that
doesn't bode well for people as you see
what I love about this is after Simon
gives the sleep word makes her go to
sleep because she obviously she has
subliminal messaging in her brain mal
goes over and picks her up and brings
her back onto serenity and the doctor
comes with he had an out he could have
just left him there it's like a whatever
not my problem that's not his way as
much as he wants to come across as a
hardened dick and is sometimes he
actually has a heart of gold like I said
in my series review of Firefly and I
give this movie credit it doesn't pick
up right where the show left off and
ours not on the ship anymore she's
training other companions on this other
world Shepard books not on the ship
either he could have just as easily had
them on the ship and been like oh no
it's like a day later you can tell some
time has passed not much time with the
Nara because she did illustrate at the
end of the series she's like I'm leaving
serenity so there is that but you know
books gone now and he's changed his hair
he's got cornrows now basic preacher
hairstyle I guess and of course books
like they're gonna keep this quiet now
they're gonna come at you sideways like
velociraptors they're gonna send it
operative they want this kept quiet and
Mel's like you know an awful lot about
this book and you're like you know an
awful lot about this book and Mel's like
you got to tell me about how you know
about this sometime and books like no I
don't and no he won't and we'll never
know unless you read a graphic novel I
guess but we'll never know would have
loved to now what is Miranda they find
Miranda it's a planet they're like I
yeah something about the terraforming
didn't
and there were a couple little
settlements but that was it but they get
down to Miranda and they're like nah
nothing's wrong with this place just
everyone's dead but it's not like
everyone got wasted and killed and wiped
out just everyone's just kind of dead
and you find out the Alliance
manufactured this chemical in which they
used Miranda as a testing grounds for
and this chemical was supposed to subdue
people and make them less violent less
aggravated less irritable which everyone
stopped caring about anything and
everything and stopped caring about
having sex or going to work or sleeping
and it just laid down and they were like
oh we're just gonna lay here cuz we
don't care so they're like oh we're
starving to death but we don't care you
know we don't care and everyone just
died yeah that would be bad enough
information to have against the Alliance
but here's the best part a tenth of a
percent of the population had the
opposite effect on them they became
irritable and enraged and angry and
started scraping at each other and
killing people and raping people and
you're like holy [ __ ] they created the
Reavers the Alliance wiped out an entire
planet and created the Reavers that's
that's pretty bad smear campaigning
right there that you got against him and
after that I love this monologue that
mal gives he gives this whole monologue
run of his crew and he's like you all
got on this boat for different reasons
but now I'm going to ask more of you
than I ever have and you just goes on
from there every time I see it I get a
little choked up you're like this is
this is awesome it's mal going no more
running we are going to go at them so
the got this idea to go to mr. universe
which is this guy on this planet who's
pretty much proof positive that brain
cancer has been cured in the future
because this guy lives on a planet where
all the information goes just as big
information hub you can see electronic
information floating around this world
and the guy doesn't have brain cancer no
brain cancer is no longer around in the
future apparently guy would have died
after being there for a week and I love
this part because the operative is there
with this warship and a few Alliance
ships mal comes through the clouds and
he was like best is not even changing
coals and all these Reaver ships just
boom come through the clouds because mal
is pretty much like alright we got to
fly through Reaver space and he was like
hey waivered [ __ ] and they followed him
he brings them right to the doorstep and
he's like here you deal with them I need
to go to mr. universe and get a signal
out and this is the only time you see
the operative really lose his [ __ ] he's
like target the reapers target the ships
is somebody fire yeah not so calm now
are ya the worst debt just the dumbest
death in movie history
right here wash just gets killed just
blinked out of it he's dead I'm a leaf
on the wind
what did white dude is totally Boba Fett
it in fact no he wasn't Boba Fett 'add
Boba Fett was washed actually I like
that washed alright here it is from now
on when someone has a stupid just out of
the blue death in a movie I'm no longer
gonna call it Boba Fett it it's now
known as being washed but he just dies
and you're like why'd you die earlier on
in the movie Shepherd book died and I
kind of get that dads are like okay we
need to wipe out everywhere that
serenity goes to to rest up and hide and
so now we're just gonna wipe everyone
out Sheppard book was there so he died I
can buy that in the movie someone is
probably gonna die but book and wash
wash for no reason whatsoever you can
argue that it had to get Zoe into mode
and she had to be like okay it's a fight
to the death now I'm a soldier again I'm
pretty sure she would have fought to
keep wash alive had he lived through the
landing in any case neither here nor
there everyone's making their stand and
now mal goes down to get the signal out
in which he has to fight the operative
what I love about it is mal is really
physically no match for this operative
but you do see it in mouths mine in his
brain earlier on in the movie book told
him he's like the thing that's gonna get
you through this is belief and he wasn't
talking about God even though he is a
preacher he was just saying belief
because this operative really truly
believes that killing River Tam is the
right thing to do and mouths
face-to-face with him he's like the rest
of the verse is going to know what
happened and the operatives like do you
really believe that Mel's like I do and
he goes are you willing to die for that
belief and mal just stops he's like I am
and you see it you're like mal that's
why you're a badass too and after a
fight in which it's not really a fight
its mal more or less getting his ass
kicked and stabbed he gets a couple good
hits in there though but this is rivers
time to be like hey this is what the
Alliance was doing with me and this is
how I'm gonna use it for us she goes in
there she tears [ __ ] into these Reavers
we're talking this chick is immaculate
any fighter in any movie she can take
any of them on this chick would probably
get a flawless victory against Shao Kahn
himself the cheapest boss and fighting
game history River would do it she
cleans them all out and in the end of
this movie they get the signal out and
everyone's just in bad shape but the
operatives like damage done stand down
it's it's done there's no need to kill
them now and also you can argue that he
didn't see the information before
because he's one of the guys who's like
I'm an operative I don't ask questions
and Mal's like I'm gonna show you this
is your world without sin this is what
the Alliance does you can
the operatives like ya I'm still the
human being that sucks ass
as far as douchebags who got Shepherd
book killed he's not a bad dude he's
just an [ __ ] sometimes
serenity wasn't the plan Joss Whedon I'm
sure had more to do with the stories
like mal said to the operatives likes
not exactly plan a but with an
hour-and-a-half window to theatrically
wrap up his Firefly saga he did the best
job possible and the first theatrically
released motion picture you've ever done
and this is no wonder he got the
Avengers job seriously this were any
other movie and I wasn't attached to the
characters and this was just a movie in
theaters that I saw I'd probably say
it's buy it on blu-ray type of situation
but since this is a really satisfying
conclusion to an epic story in which
I've gotten involved with these
characters and it's a really easy movie
to watch you can pop it in and be like
let's be entertained for an hour and a
half or an hour 45 minutes whatever
serenity is awesome tacular
so that's my conclusion to the Serenity
movie review it's not like it's as epic
as serenity the movie but hey now you
got your Firefly review now you got your
serenity review life is good at least
for me because I like talking about it
so have you seen serenity what did you
think of it wasn't everything you wanted
the conclusion of Firefly to be comment
below let me know and as always if you
like what you've seen here and you want
to see more click right here to see more
low seems you first one more time for
good measure I want to resolve this like
civilized men I'm not threatening you
I'm unarmed good